une minute de silence dans tous les
établissements scolaires de France c'est
l'hommage qui a été rendu aujourd'hui à
14h à Dominique Bernard le professeur de
français a été poignardé à mort vendredi
lors d'une attaque terroriste survenue
dans un collège lycée d'aras dans le Pas
de Calais la première ministre Elisabeth
borne et le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Gabriel Atal ont choisi le
collège du bois d'ulne à Conflant
saint-onorine pour assister à cet
hommage c'est là qu'enseignait Samuel
paatti autre victime du terrorisme
islamiste le professeur
d'histoiregéographie avait été tué à
proximité de l'établissement il y a 3
ans jour pour jour le 16 octobre 2020
elélisabeth bornne et Gabriel Atal sont
arrivés peu avant 14h et sont restés sur
place une trentaine de minutes ils ont
pu échanger à H clos avec des collégiens
et des professeurs sur place notamment
et Nathalia pousirev député de la 6e
circonscription des evelines qui était
au micro de Gabrielle Gontier et
Mathilde Francou les échanges avec les
élèves qui étaient très attentifs
très
ouvert et qui avait le sentiment que
effectivement c'est un moment important
grave on voit bien qu'il y a des équipes
enseignantes qui sont solides qui sont
engagé pour faire en sorte qu'on
n'oublie pas mais quand même temps cette
génération puisse se projeter se sentir
en sécurité et se projeter dans dans
dans l'avenir et qu'ils aient confiance
en eux qu'ils aient confiance en la
République